This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. As baseball fans probably know, the Washington Nationals came to the US by way of Canada. They used to be the Montreal Expos. The team packed up and left Canada in 2005, and they left behind their name, their logo, their uniforms. And maybe, most importantly, their mascot, UP. That's our Canadian friend Andrew Norton. He has a special connection to UP. It's actually my dad who had the special connection
这里是“99%无形”。我是罗曼·马斯。正如棒球迷们大概知道的那样，华盛顿国民队是通过加拿大来到美国的。他们以前叫蒙特利尔博览会队。这支球队在2005年收拾行装离开了加拿大，留下了他们的名字、队徽、队服。也许最重要的是，还有他们的吉祥物——尤比（Youppi）。那是我们的加拿大朋友安德鲁·诺顿。他和尤比有着特殊的联系。其实是我爸爸和尤比有着特殊的联系。
to UP. He died about eight years ago and his relationship with UP is something that I'm still trying to square. Okay, so a little bit about my dad. He was the boring dad. He always fell asleep at the movies. Pinocchio, toy story, dude was out cold. Family trips were planned with efficiency and thrift as the primary objective. And at our house, we subscribed to the one newspaper that didn't have a comic section. He was definitely not into things that could be classified as fun. But he had this one quiet obsession. It was rotund, orange, free, and six and a half feet tall. U.P. U.P. Spelled, why O.U. P.P.I. and always with an exclamation mark. It's French for Yippee, you know, like, Yippee. Oh, like UP! Oh, oh, oh, oh!
他大约在八年前去世了，他和尤比之间的关系是我至今仍在试图弄明白的事情。好吧，先说说我爸爸。他是个无趣的爸爸。他在看电影时总是睡着。《木偶奇遇记》、《玩具总动员》，这家伙睡得死死的。家庭旅行是以高效率和节约作为首要目标来规划的。在我们家，我们只订购了一份没有漫画版的报纸。他绝对不喜欢那些可以被归类为有趣的事情。但他有一个安静的痴迷。它圆滚滚、橙色、毛茸茸、身高六英尺半。尤比。尤比。拼写是Y-O-U-P-P-I，而且总是带着一个感叹号。这是法语里的“太棒了”，你知道的，就像“太噢，就像尤比！哦，哦，哦，哦！”
Monji, um, honestly, haven't looked at UP in a while. That's my sister Jessica. We're in her basement while her kids are asleep, and we're looking at photos of UP on my phone. That's the UP I know. Orange, fuzzy, wearing cleats, exos hat, ill-feeding exos shirt, and then like, googly eyes, but an approachable face.
梦姬，嗯，老实说，我有一阵子没看尤比了。那是我的姐姐杰西卡。我们在她的地下室里，趁她的孩子们睡着了，我们在我手机上看着尤比的照片。那是我认识的尤比。橙色、毛茸茸、穿着球鞋、博览会队的帽子、不合身的博览会队球衣，然后还有像滑稽的眼睛，但有着平易近人的脸。
UP looks like an orange-haired bearded lumberjack cross with a Sasquatch wearing a baseball jersey. You can picture that, right? It was when we were kids that my sister and I started noticing our dad's affection for UP. He light up when we'd see him at expo's games and he'd look for him on TV. He hated when the game would get cut too commercial because that would be prime UP time. UP brought out this side of my dad
尤比看起来就像是一个橙色头发、长着胡子的伐木工，和一个穿着棒球衣的大脚怪的结合体。你能想象出来吧？我和姐姐就是在我们小时候开始注意到爸爸对尤比的喜爱的。当我们看到他在博览会队的比赛中出现时，他会兴奋起来，而且他会在电视上寻找他。他讨厌比赛被广告打断，因为那是尤比的黄金时间。尤比激发了我爸爸的这一面，
that we just didn't recognize. All of a sudden, you're just a guy who loves the mascot. To the point where you clip a picture of him out of the newspaper and put him on the side of the fridge. An article on the fridge might not sound like a big deal, but before this, the only other article he had ever posted up was about Canada's new sales tax rates. Then suddenly, it's UPI. It should be noted that when the expose moved to DC to become the nationals, UPI switched
这是我们根本不了解的。突然之间，你成了一个热爱吉祥物的家伙。甚至到了这种程度：你把一张他的照片从报纸上剪下来，贴在冰箱侧面上。冰箱上贴一篇文章听起来可能不算什么大事，但在那之前，他唯一贴过的另一篇文章是关于加拿大新销售税率的。然后突然之间，就变成了尤比。需要说明的是，当博览会队搬到华盛顿成为国民队时，尤比改变了
sports and found a job with a Montreal hockey team called the Canadians. My dad died just after that, and all these years later, I can't help but wonder what it was about UP that spoke to his long repressed whimsical side. And it's not just Andrew's dad. So many grown adults can't resist hugging and posing for selfies with mascots. Even though it's just someone in a costume, they're entranced. Well, I mean the definition of the mascot, like it comes from actually the French word
运动项目，并在蒙特利尔的一支名叫加拿大人队的冰球队找到了一份工作。我爸爸在那之后不久就去世了，这些年过去了，我不禁想知道，尤比到底有什么魔力，触动了他长期被压抑的异想天开的一面。而且不仅是安德鲁的爸爸。如此多的成年人无法抗拒拥抱吉祥物并与它们合影。尽管那只是一个穿着戏服的人，但他们着迷了。好吧，我的意思是吉祥物的定义，它实际上来自于法语单词
uh, masco, a little slang word, which actually means which. That's AJ Masse, writer for ESPN.com, and author of a book all about sports mascots called Yes. It's Houghton here. He was also in the dude inside the Mr. Met costume from 1994 till 1997. In 1997, when Bill Clinton was visiting Shaya Stadium, the secret service pulled AJ aside while he was in his big Mr. Met costume and told him, if you approach the president, we go for the kill shot.
呃，mascotte，一个俚语，实际上意思是女巫。那是AJ·马斯，ESPN.com的撰稿人，也是一本关于体育吉祥物的书《是的，这里是霍顿》的作者。他还在1994年至1997年期间扮演过大都市先生服装里面的那个家伙。1997年，当比尔·克林顿访问谢亚体育场时，特勤局在大都市先生的大服装里把AJ拉到一边对他说，如果你靠近总统，我们就直接开枪击毙你。
According to AJ, the word mascot came to America in the late 1800s through a French opera. That was called La mascotte by a guy named Audrian. The opera is about a down on his luck farmer who's visited by this girl named Bettina. As soon as she rolls up, magically his crops start doing well and his life turns around. All thanks to this mysterious woman. And it became very popular in the United States and the terminology kind of caught on where people realize and recognize that mascot means a good luck charm. And this idea of a mascot fit right in with the notoriously superstitious world of pro
据AJ说，吉祥物这个词是在19世纪后期通过一部法国歌剧传入美国的。那部歌剧叫《吉祥物》，作者是一个叫奥德兰的人。这部歌剧讲的是一个运气不佳的农夫，他遇到了一个叫贝蒂娜的女孩。她一出现，他的庄园就神奇地开始好转，生活也发生了转机。这一切都要归功于这个神秘的女人。它在美国变得非常流行，这个术语也随之流行起来，人们意识到并承认吉祥物意味着好运的护身符。这种吉祥物的想法与职业界臭名昭著的迷信世界不谋而合。
baseball. You know, there were situations where like there'd be a kid in the stand who would smile at a baseball player in a slump, he'd get a base hit and he'd give the kid tickets for the next day. And you know, and suddenly he'd go on a big hitting streak and so he would be like, hey, I want this kid to hang around all the time and that's kind of where mascots became these human good luck charms. Like John the Orange Man, who was well a man who sold oranges outside the stadium at Harvard
棒球。你知道，有些情况下，比如看台上有个小孩对一个处于低迷状态的棒球运动员微笑，他就会击出一支安打，并送给那个小孩第二天的门票。你知道的，突然间他就会迎来连续安打的高潮，所以他就会想，嘿，我希望这个小孩一直待在附近，这就是吉祥物如何成为这种人类好运护身符的由来。比如橙色人约翰，他实际上是一个在哈佛体育场外卖橘子的男人，
and Yale adopted handsome Dan Bulldog. They walked out onto the field before games. Anything that was sort of around at the time of a team's hot streak adopted handsome Dan, a bulldog they walked out onto the field before games. Anything that was sort of a round at the time of a team's hot streak could and would be claimed as a mascot. It was pretty much all animals and bystanders until the Second World War. That's when one baseball game altered the idea of mascots in sports. Yeah, this game took place in Hawaii, and it was an exhibition game made up of service members. Pitching was kind of a lanky goofy looking guy by the name of Max Patkin. The legendary
而耶鲁大学则收养了英俊的丹斗牛犬。他们在比赛前走到场上。任何在球队处于连胜期间恰好在场的东西，都可以并且将会被宣称是吉祥物。在第二次世界大战之前，基本上全都是动物和旁观者。就在那时，一场棒球比赛改变了体育界对吉祥物的看法。是的，这场比赛在夏威夷举行，这是一场由军人组成的表演赛。投球的是一个身材修长、滑稽的家伙，名叫马克斯·帕特金。传奇人物
Joe DiMaggio steps up to the plate and hits a massive home runoff. The story goes that the ball went into the Pacific Ocean. And Patkin just snaps. He jumps off the mound. This is the picture, okay? He jumps off the mound and runs after Dimasio. People thought he was going to attack him or something, but actually he just ran behind him mimicking his home run trot, and the crowd just went nuts. So he kept doing this act throughout those service league exhibition games as a pitcher. His stick was sort of a mix of Jim Kary and Ace Ventura, meets the dance moves of your drunk uncle at a wedding, meets like a Parisian mine.
乔·迪马乔走上打击区，击出了一记巨大的全垒打。故事说，球飞进了太平洋。帕特金当场抓狂了。他跳下投手丘。这就是画面，好吧？他跳下投手丘，追着迪马乔跑。人们以为他要袭击他什么的，但实际上他只是在他身后模仿他跑垒的动作，观众顿时疯狂了。所以他在那些军人联赛表演赛中一直作为投球手进行这个表演。他的滑稽动作有点像金·凯瑞和神探阿杰的结合体，加上你在婚礼上喝醉的叔叔的舞步，再加上一点巴黎哑剧演员的感觉。
And when the war was over, Pac can stop being a pitcher and was hired by the Cleveland Indians to do his thing at home games to help draw in crowds. It was the first time a mascot did more than just stand around being lucky. He entertained people. And God knows people need that at a baseball game. So now thanks to Packin we have this idea of a mascot as a diversion. But there's still a big evolutionary step to get to the mascots we know today. Yeah, the turning point certainly has to begin and end with the chicken. The San Diego chicken who can really only be described
战争结束后，帕特金不再当投球手，被克利夫兰印第安人队聘用，在主场比赛中表演他的绝活来吸引观众。这是吉祥物第一次不仅仅站在那里带来好运气。他娱乐了大众。上帝知道人们在棒球比赛中需要这个。所以现在多亏了帕特金，我们有了将吉祥物视为消遣的想法。但要达到我们今天所知的吉祥物，仍有很大的一步进化。是的，转折点肯定要从这只鸡开始，并在这只鸡身上结束。圣迭戈鸡，它其实只能被形容为
as a dude in a chicken suit. In 1974, the San Diego radio station KGBFM hired a college kid by the name of Ted Giannulis to wear a chicken suit and do promotion for the radio station. And Giannulis got into it, like really into it. The chicken had bravado, he had swagger, he was like an obnoxious frat boy and a bird costume. He danced on the field at San Diego Padres games, grabbed people's beer and pretend to chug it. And the Padres were
一个穿着鸡戏服的家伙。1974年，圣迭戈广播电台KGB-FM雇了一个叫泰德·吉安努利斯的大学生穿着鸡戏服为广播电台做宣传。吉安努利斯全身心投入进去了，真的是全身心投入。这只鸡有傲气，有架势，他就像一个穿着鸟戏服令人讨厌的大学兄弟会男生。他在圣迭戈教士队的比赛场上跳舞，抢走人们的啤酒并假装一饮而尽。教士队当时是
such a bad team that people started going just so they could see the chicken perform. And that's where the San Diego chicken kind of was born. He was this this marketing tool for the radio station that kind of Suddenly became bigger than the team itself He was eventually fired from the radio station because he took on such a life of his own So Jean-Nuelis got his own chicken costume and kept performing the station actually suit him and lost because it's you can't you know You can't copyright the idea of guy in chicken suit kids You can't copyright the idea of guy in chicken suit. Kids, you can't copyright the idea of a guy in a chicken suit.
如此糟糕的一支球队，以至于人们开始去那里仅仅是为了看这只鸡表演。这就是圣迭戈鸡诞生的由来。他是广播电台的一种营销工具，突然之间变得比球队本身还要大。他最终被广播电台解雇了，因为他拥有了如此鲜活的生命。所以吉安努利斯弄了他自己的鸡戏服并继续表演，电台实际上起诉了他并且败诉了，因为你不能，你知道，你不能对穿着鸡戏服的家伙这个创意申请版权，孩子们。你不能对穿着鸡戏服的家伙这个创意申请版权。孩子们，你不能对穿着鸡戏服的家伙这个创意申请版权。
The chicken was a big deal. Even though he wasn't an official team mascot, he had become an icon. He created the modern mascot movement. Even so, by the late 70s, the mascot scene was still pretty barren by today's standards. Only a handful of baseball teams technically had mascots, like the Philadelphia Phillies. They had a pair of characters called Phil and Phyllis. They were props. They weren't mascots.
这只鸡是一件大事。尽管他不是官方的球队吉祥物，但他已经成了一个偶像。他开创了现代吉祥物运动。即便如此，到70年代末，按今天的标准来看，吉祥物界仍然相当荒凉。只有少数几支棒球队在技术上拥有吉祥物，比如费城费城人队。他们有一对名叫菲尔和菲儿的吉祥物。他们是道具。他们不是吉祥物。
They were props. Picture if you dressed a couple of those big boy restaurant statues in colonial garb, they were these big plaster characters that would kind of waddle out for the national anthem or if there was a home run. So when the Philly saw what the chicken was doing in San Diego, they were like, we got to get us some of that. The Philly's found someone to custom design a mascot to entertain their fans. And before she came on board, they warned her that fans in Philly could be a little unforgiving. They said, well, we just want you to know that our crowd in Philadelphia booed the Easter bunny.
他们是道具。想象一下，如果你给几个那些大男孩餐厅雕像穿上殖民时期的服装，他们就是那种会摇摇晃晃地走出来迎接国歌或者当有全垒打时的巨大石膏角色。所以当费城人队看到这只鸡在圣迭戈的所作所为时，他们想，我们也得弄个那样的。费城人队找人定制了一个吉祥物来娱乐他们的球迷。在她加入之前，他们警告她，费城球迷有时可能有点冷酷无情。他们说，嗯，我们只是想让你知道，我们在费城的观众嘘过复活节兔子。
That's designer Bonnie Erickson, and the booing the Easter bunny story is actually an urban legend. But Eagles fans did once Pelt Santa with snowballs during the game. Bonnie had no experience with the sports world when she took the gig. She and her husband and business partner Wade Harris then had just started their own design outfit. And they got the Philly's job thanks to a recommendation by Bonnie's former employer, Jim Henson. The Jim Henson.
那是设计师邦妮·埃里克森，而“嘘复活节兔子”的故事其实是一个都市传说。但在比赛期间，老鹰队球迷确实曾用雪球砸过圣诞老人。邦妮在接下这份工作时对体育界毫无经验。她和她的丈夫兼商业伙伴韦德·哈里斯当时刚开始他们自己的设计公司。由于邦妮的前老板吉姆·汉森的推荐，他们得到了费城人队的工作。就是那个吉姆·汉森。
You know, Muppets, Fraggle Rock, Sesame Street, Bonnie Erickson designed Miss Peggy. And the Muppet Show Hecklers, Stattler, and Waldorf. I wonder if there's anything she isn't good at. Yes, choosing what showed her beyond. She also worked with Henson on making life-sized versions of the Sesame Street characters for their Sesame Street on ice performances. So, she knew how to make a costume that people could perform and move in, which was a new concept when it came to mascots. So Bonnie got to work on this new mascot, and in the meantime, the Phillies had to find
你知道的，布偶、脆莓岩、芝麻街，邦妮·埃里克森设计了佩姬小姐。还有布偶秀里的挑剔观众，史塔特勒和沃尔多夫。我想知道有没有什么是她不擅长的。是的，选择展示什么。她还与汉森合作，为他们的“冰上芝麻街”表演制作了真人大小的芝麻街角色。所以，她知道如何制作一个人们可以穿着表演和移动的服装，这在吉祥物领域是一个全新的概念。因此邦妮开始着手设计这个新吉祥物，与此同时，费城人队必须找到
someone to stuff inside of it and face those Santa-heckling grounds. They needed the lowest man on the totem pole, the intern, to raise his hand and say yes. That's Dave Raymond, who was that intern. He was brought on board to do things like count the all-star game voting ballots. He had no background as a performer, aside from some dabbling with disco. Nevertheless, he would be the performer inside this new mascot. Because of some delays, we didn't see the costume until the very night that I was going to wear it. And that's when I started getting a little bit Distressed because I started to realize that everyone else thought this was a stupid idea and and I was truly gonna be thrown to the wolves
一个人塞进里面去面对那些嘘圣诞老人的看台。他们需要食物链底端的那个人，也就是实习生，来举手说“我愿意”。那是戴夫·雷蒙德，他就是那个实习生。他被招进来做一些事情，比如清点全明星赛的选票。除了偶尔涉足迪斯科之外，他没有任何作为表演者的背景。尽管如此，他将成为这个新吉祥物里面的表演者。由于一些耽搁，直到我将要穿上它的那个晚上，我们才见到这套戏服。就在那时我开始感到有点苦恼，因为我开始意识到其他所有人，都认为这是一个愚蠢的主意，而我真的会被扔给狼群。
The Phillies weren't even promoting the fact that they were getting a new mascot in case the whole thing just completely backfired They could be like mascot one mascot. Did you see a mascot? I didn't see a mascot But I was reassured when I first What mascot? Did you see a mascot? I didn't see a mascot. But I was reassured when I first opened the box and I was blown away with how how perfect it looked. The Philly Phanatic was born. If this were a superhero movie, this would be when the dramatic music comes on. But the Phanatic is definitely not a comic book superhero. It's all green fur like like very furry fuzzy fur. He has a snout like a megaphone.
费城人队甚至没有宣传他们将迎来一个新吉祥物，以防万一整个事情彻底砸锅。他们可以说：吉祥物一号？吉祥物？你看到吉祥物了吗？我没看到吉祥物。但当我第一次打开箱子时，我感到很安心，我被它看起来有多完美震撼到了。费城疯狂鸡（Philly Phanatic）诞生了。如果这是一部超级英雄电影，这时候戏剧性的音乐就该响起了。但疯狂鸡绝对不是漫画书里的超级英雄。它全身都是绿色的毛，就像非常浓密的毛茸茸的毛。它的鼻子像一个扩音器。
He's very, very large and rotund, pear-shaped body with a huge belly and a kind of a duck butt. A very long neck. Stir-up socks, fillies hat and a fillies jersey. Perfect, you know, doesn't that all make sense? No, no, it doesn't make any sense that the Philly's mascot would be a big, Google-Eye monster. But it turns out that every part of the fanatic is like a masterclass in mascot design.
它非常非常大而且圆滚滚，梨形的身体带着一个大肚子和有点像鸭子的屁股。很长的脖子。蹬踩袜，费城人帽子和费城人球衣。完美，你知道，难道这一切不都合情合理吗？不，不，费城人队的吉祥物是一个巨大的、凸眼睛的怪物，这根本说不通。但事实证明，疯狂鸡的每个部分都堪称吉祥物设计的艺术典范。
For starters, he's green. Not the standard Philly's red. Right, exactly. It's always easy to spot the fanatic in any of these games. And the duck butt and the pear-shaped body? No matter how you move in that costume, if you're a human being and you put one leg in front of the other, that costume looks funny. Now when I look at the fanatic, it's so clear that there's Muppet DNA there. Even the placement of the cartoon Google-Eyes is something that Bonnie learned from her time designing Muppets.
首先，它是绿色的。不是标准的费城人红。对，没错。在任何这些比赛中总是很容易发现疯狂鸡。还有鸭子屁股和梨形身体？无论你在这套戏服里怎么动，如果你是一个人类，并且你把一条腿放在另一条腿前面，这套戏服看起来就很滑稽。现在当我看着疯狂鸡时，很明显那里有着布偶（Muppet）的DNA。甚至卡通凸眼睛的位置也是邦妮从她设计布偶的时期学到的东西。
You are asking for all my secrets. Well, if you put eyes high on a figure's face, they will look older. If you put them down closer to the nose, they'll probably look younger and more childlike. Plus, there's other mascot first that she borrowed from the Muppets. Like, she designed the fanatic with licensing and merchandising in mind.
你这是在打听我所有的秘密。好吧，如果你把眼睛放在一个形象脸部的高处，它们看起来就会更老。如果你把它们放得离鼻子更近，它们可能看起来更年轻、更有孩子气。另外，她还借鉴了布偶的其他吉祥物第一。比如，她在设计疯狂鸡时就考虑到了特许经营和商品化。
Toys, t-shirts, that kind of stuff. And like all good characters, the fanatic even has his own origin story. He's supposedly from the Galapagos Islands. The fanatic is goofy. You know, he'd rub a bald dude's head or rip off the hat of someone cheering for the wrong team. And usually he gets away with it.
玩具、T恤，诸如此类的东西。而且像所有优秀的角色一样，疯狂鸡甚至有他自己的背景故事。据说他来自加拉帕戈斯群岛。疯狂鸡很滑稽。你知道的，他会揉一个秃头男人的头，或者扯掉一个为错误球队加油的人的帽子。而且通常他总能逃脱惩罚。
It's just damn near impossible to get irate with a fuzzy green thing. The one time he did get pummeled by Tommy Lasorta, the coach of the LA Dodgers, after Lasorta had had it with the fanatic taunting him. That's the quickest Tommy's moved all year. We gotta mark that down. The quickest Tommy Lasorta moved in 1988 was after the Philly Phenatic. Oh, what a deal. And of course, that just made the Philly's fans love them even more.
对一个毛茸茸的绿色怪物发火简直是不可能的。他唯一一次遭到洛杉矶道奇队教练汤米·拉索塔的痛殴，是在拉索塔受够了疯狂鸡对他的嘲讽之后。那是汤米一整年里动得最快的一次。我们得记下来。汤米·拉索塔在1988年动得最快的一次是在对付费城疯狂鸡之后。哦，多棒的一幕啊。当然，这只会让费城球迷更加爱戴他。
Day Raymond played the Philly Phenatic from that first game in 1978 until 1993. He only ever missed five home games. Now all but three major league baseball teams have mascots, and most of them are big and furry and goofy and have googly eyes. Everyone since the fanatic is kind of in a way copying the fanatic. And so of course Bonnie kept getting work. After we did the fanatic, the next one that we were asked to do because of the popularity of the character early on was for Montreal for the expose.
戴夫·雷蒙德从1978年的第一场比赛一直扮演费城疯狂鸡到1993年。他只缺席过五场主场比赛。现在除了三支美国职棒大联盟球队外，其余都有吉祥物，而且它们大多又大、又毛茸茸、很滑稽并且有凸出的眼睛。自疯狂鸡以来的每个人都在某种程度上模仿疯狂鸡。所以当然邦妮不断接到工作。在我们做了疯狂鸡之后，由于这个角色早期受欢迎的程度，我们被要求做的下一个是为蒙特利尔的博览会队设计的。
Yep, Bonnie Erickson also created UPI. And when I told her about the inordinate amount of affection my dad had for the mascot, she recalled once seeing a big, burly guy coming out of the Expo's stadium with some UPI dolls in a shopping bag. He had positioned them so that they would have their heads sticking out, as if they couldn't breathe if they weren't. And I thought that was very touching. The mascot still lives in this sort of limbo between the two worlds.
是的，邦妮·埃里克森也创作了尤比。当我和她谈起我爸爸对这个吉祥物超乎寻常的喜爱时，她回忆起曾看到一个身材高大魁梧的家伙手里提着一个装有几个尤比玩偶的购物袋走出博览会队的体育场。他把它们摆好，让它们的脑袋露在外面，就好像如果它们不这样就会无法呼吸一样。我觉得这很感人。这个吉祥物依然活在介于这两个世界之间的某种灰色地带。
He's not quite part of the team, but not quite part of the fanbase either. I think that's the power of a mascot. What fan of a team wouldn't want to be able to have that freedom to mock the other team and get a response? You know, they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they li- they know, they lif I garriously for the mascot. I think a big part of it for my dad was this aspect of living vicariously. UPI was his spirit animal, the Brad Pitt to his Edward Norton.
他既不完全属于球队，也不完全属于球迷群体。我想这就是吉祥物的力量。哪个球队的球迷会不想拥有那种可以嘲笑对方球队并得到回应的自由呢？你知道，他们代入式地为吉祥物疯狂。我认为对于我爸爸来说，其中很大一部分是这种代入式生活的方面。尤比是他的精神动物，是他心中的布拉德·皮特（对爱德华·诺顿而言）。
UPI could belly slide across the exposed dugout, take the ump to task while the whole stadium cheered him on, steal a kiss from Celine Dion after a show-stopping rendition of O Canada. U.P. is a fun dude, and I can see that maybe secretly my dad was too. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Andrew Norton with Sam Green's fan Katie Mingle, Avery Trouffleman, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of ArcSign, an architecture and interiors firm in beautiful, downtown Oakland, California.
尤比可以滑腹穿过博览会队的休息区，在整个体育场的欢呼声中对裁判提出质疑，在一曲震撼人心的《哦，加拿大》表演后偷走席琳·迪翁的一个吻。尤比是一个有趣的家伙，我能看出也许我爸爸私下里也是这样。“99%无形”本周由安德鲁·诺顿与萨姆·格林斯潘、凯蒂·明格尔、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼以及我罗曼·马斯共同制作。我们是旧金山91.7KALW的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的建筑和室内设计公司ArcSign的办公室制作。
and architecture and interiors firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. We're all on Twitter and Instagram. Avery runs the Tumblr. I make the Spotify playlist of 99PI songs, but I encourage you to explore the entire world of 99% invisible at 99pi.org Radio to P.R.X. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的建筑和室内设计公司ArcSign办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我们都在Twitter和Instagram上。艾弗里负责Tumblr。我制作99PI歌曲的Spotify播放列表，但我鼓励你在99pi.org Radio to P.R.X上探索“99%无形”的整个世界。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。